[Music]
a colorado man who killed his wife and
staged it to look like an accident was
uh found guilty of a murder
and the funny part is
he used his dead wife's life insurance
policy to pay for his defense lawyer
oh [ __ ] is that legal that's [ __ ] i
don't know if that's going to be legal
well it is because uh he's paying for it
he's paying for it while he's defending
himself from being guilty of her murder
that's so he's not proven yet yeah not
yet but once he is proven then he has to
pay that money back i think yeah if he's
proven he's gone
but i mean it is the heist it's kind of
a hack what was the scheme yeah how do
you do it
basically his wife catches him cheating
it's johnny depp
it's an unrelated that's an ad
hey we should talk about that that one
was adriana's insurance
it's um so what happens is uh this guy
gets confronted by his wife she's like
converting about cheating
he kills her as you know usually
supposed to yeah she knows too much you
know as you do and he chokes her out in
the i guess like in the it makes it look
like she slipped in the shower
with [ __ ] fingerprints right here
yeah this fingerprint marks on her neck
you're right right it's so like
it took
sucks yeah he's freaking super sucks but
the crazy thing is
even though the family was like this
must drive you nuts if this is you but
like they were so convinced he killed
her but they couldn't find
um an autopsy person a forensics
expert
that was willing to say that it was
strangulation
versus what was the other cause of death
slipping in the shower the old classic
whoopsie days what but there's no blunt
force or anything that was that's the
thing it's like it's like uh he made it
look like because he slammed her head
yeah she slammed her [ __ ] is he like
powerful or something in this
neighborhood where no one else is a
regular [ __ ] guy where is this easy
denver denver
what the [ __ ] wait so then how would
they know that he choked her then if
noah would say that she
why are people trying to hide this three
years later they found they found um an
expert who was willing to testify that
that's what he thought it was
whoa wait why did they not want to say
that's the cause i think like a lot of
the time if you're not a hundred percent
sure um you're kind of putting your
career on the line like oh you know
that's true most people like if it
looked like majority of the crime scene
was a slip and fall then they're gonna
be like oh it's a classic slip and fall
yeah
i don't know that's so interesting yeah
so it took three years for them to find
that even in that community where you
expect it to be objective and be like
yeah let's just look at everything and
see what the info says even in that
community people are still like well i'm
not gonna say it yeah and i think that's
a very overlooked thing is like a lot of
people don't understand that those are
also careers like those are careers that
they don't want to lose either so
they're not just gonna go on your hunch
you know and it took them forever when
they did find that person they opened
that investigation up and they found
yeah who accused them of killing again
uh her family so her family was like i
don't trust this problem just [ __ ]
new yeah
i knew
like she's not a clumsy [ __ ] three
years of having to deal with that yeah
oh my god and i think and on top of that
they're like there's no way this [ __ ]
was gonna [ __ ] slip because she had
all of those sticky things on her
bathtub mm-hmm she had handles
everywhere in that bag yet the handles
and the sticky things on the bottom
and then she's like come on and she has
size 12 feet baby just three years of
like you're hanging out like eating
you're like
there's just no way she felt bro
every day you think about that [ __ ] the
crazy thing is this murder actually
happened in 2015. it wasn't until 2018
that they were able to charge him and it
wasn't until now that they found him
guilty so it took [ __ ] forever and
that's why he already has the payout he
has
[Music]
i would have thought i was in the clear
hell dude yeah you're scot-free they
have kids yeah they have kids
if you're smart they don't say the age
but they look like they're literally
yeah
they're babies
they're gonna grow up and be like [ __ ]
you dad i bet the corner probably was
like yeah it's standard slip and fall
i'm not gonna look at it yeah we'll just
say yeah that's what it is signed off on
it is so disturbing yeah how much
that's probably really happened in the
day-to-day like people get jaded and
[ __ ] you know like they just like yeah
whatever i've seen this so many times
before there he is eric estrada himself
threat to pier wow
damn bro
dude just take the l if she catches you
cheating bro for real why you gotta why
are you choking out like judging by the
rest of his [ __ ] behavior he probably
just saw the um the child support and
spousal support he'd have to pay and was
just like no i'm [ __ ] kill her
know
because if he's willing to like spend
her life insurance money on his defense
case then yeah this guy is probably
seeing dollar bills and everything he
does that's [ __ ] up super shitty
give him give him uh the death penalty
immediately
i think
every day what they have to do
is take
um
a little notch it's not even a full
centimeter you know you get a ruler and
you get a small notch and you razor
blade a piece of his dick i like jelly
it goes all the way
oh that's tired yeah
every day like
garlic yeah fine garlic add a you just
slice one piece like a jersey mike's
meat slicer exactly
and if you make too thick of a piece you
get in trouble
because it's like hey don't [ __ ] give
the customers
there's so much dick
dick's life poetic justice for this guy
mr poetic justice expert
i don't know i was actually just
thinking i'm like man if geo died and i
came back and i was like yo
jill's family i killed her
i think they might be like no you did it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] she probably fell down
she fell in the shower would try to
claim credit it's opposite holy [ __ ] i
did it
i killed her with these manly hands and
they're like no you did it you [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] she fell around
it is crazy because that's a true bar
take right there bro
it is true that more people die slipping
in the shower than you know probably are
killed by their husbands i would assume
because
when why or when they when people die in
the house they say it's usually they
it's a spousal [ __ ] yeah
like nine times
you know what's crazy is uh so one of my
staff
he lives in one of those like condo uh
like town homes where all the walls are
shared right
and then um recently he was like what
the [ __ ] is that smell and like the the
houses they kind of have a problem where
like it's done in the old school way
where every single thing is connected so
internet is connected all the way
through so if this person if this unit's
[ __ ] up everyone else is [ __ ] up
plumbing it's the same way and it was
smelling like [ __ ] so he was like and he
would hear like
like these goddamn rats i think a
[ __ ] rat like uh died or something in
there so they got people to go look at
the ceiling and then i think finally
when they cleared that it wasn't a rat
problem and then they smelled and there
was like flies and stuff coming out of
his neighbor's house the dude died for
30 days already holy [ __ ] but it was
during coven or something this was
literally like last month or two months
ago this happens a lot this dude was
just like like mel you know like you're
just melting and disintegrating and now
you just have flies coming in so i hate
that he's been breathing he's been
breathing like
dead people because his unit's right
next door oh [ __ ] he was for like 30
days that's dangerous he's like i have
literal dead people
parts in my body probably rotten flesh
he's got matter in his nose oh god dude
now it probably happens a lot that's
been a [ __ ] maggot buffet dude all
the flies were like
last things baby
the 30-day feast begins now
[Laughter]
because like my girlfriend will like
shower and i'll like like sometimes i'll
hear like her razor fall down or her
soap fall down and there's a moment
where i'm like oh she died
from just they're so funny because like
it's so loud you know like
like i always assume like she just fell
down in the shower yeah like i always
assume like you know funny one of the
funniest go and ask if she's okay the
funniest dark humor thing about this
what if no one has ever died sleeping in
the shower and they've all just been
murderers i know
like what if it's never really like it
happens a lot huh guys i see people i
bet people get injured a lot from
falling uh in the shower but because
girl's shower is so hot bro that's why
they fall
they do too much extra steam everywhere
well it's so hot in there
people need to start taking bubble baths
standing up and scrubbing yourself it's
dangerous overrated pass out and drown
in the bubble bath
and you know what they need to start
doing is they need to have knee length
tall grass in the shower because then
every grass
not only is it organic dude it's like
it's not it's you're never going to
sleep in that situation i want to take a
bubble bath there's a shower chair in my
hotel and i'm like i kind of want to get
this though what's a shower chair you
just sit down it's just like a stool
what do you do like squat on it but it
doesn't know that so the lighter goes
it's not a school it's like a it's like
a there's like the wall right there
you're standing in a handicapped room no
no
because there's a handicapped shower a
raft to go in
[Laughter]
no there's like a wheelchair on the door
or whatever
but like no it's just like a yeah it's a
little thing that like uh
i don't even know how to explain it like
is there anything it just folds down no
no it's just the corner of the wall and
oh i know what's talking about you can
put like a little bench yeah pulls out
no it doesn't pull out though it's
always out and you're just like wow yeah
i thought that's for old people huh can
you swivel no it's like i think it's for
where you're supposed to put
i guess you kind of could if you're
hydroplaning it's where you're supposed
to put like your shampoo and stuff like
on it yeah but i just sat on it you can
put your ass i'm like sitting on it like
you know what
i need this i thought it's for old
people i guess so i think it really is
so here's here's an interesting thing i
had to look up because i wanted to know
um
the cdc study indicates that
seventy-two percent uh the scientists
everything what the [ __ ] 72 percent
higher chance that women slip in the
shower than men why is that clumsy guys
ladies
or they're getting killed
it's you know what though it's probably
because
or they're getting killed
oh
the game pushed what if that's what's in
the shower have you guys ever fell in
the shower no but my clumsy ass grandma
did like millions of times something hey
i'd be slipping sometimes
really tell us walk us through how the
[ __ ] you slipped that's why you need to
get those [ __ ] rubber flower things
that's what the battle by the bathroom
it's usually me being cocky about
something like i can't remember like
what i could do i bet i could do this
roundhouse
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm trying to think of a time where i've
actually like fallen on my ass in the
shower
like i've slipped and i've stumbled like
oh [ __ ] and could you picture that
myself why were you even slipping
because your boy don't got the flower
not even letting him slip you gotta get
the flower [ __ ] the only way i'm
slipping is if i got [ __ ] soap and i
went like this
and then i [ __ ] try to jump hey but
this guy hey but this guy
your shower is not a bathtub bro
remember what david said about your
shower what he says you have a yellow
doesn't show you have a present shower
sometimes when you have a bathtub to
like get over it sometimes and you know
i've had those before yeah but mine's
just high brio's mom has a [ __ ] it's
this hot yeah yeah it's so high dude so
it's hard for me to get in sometimes
that's why it slips it's not your toes
it's it's regular height it's like down
here oh sometimes you just i'm gonna get
those rubber sticky uh flower things are
you right i like those we need to get
something these people must just have
bigger shower action and [ __ ] because i
can't imagine sleeping in a shower
without hitting the wall and then the
wall holding me up
yeah
yeah see
you're the one having sex in the shower
all the time i know but i didn't slip i
just i just almost bled to death
women be in the shower like
bent over shaving this is your stand-up
moment dude yeah you know women be in
the shower
so because they're shaving like you
could totally see like backing up and
like this stuff oh it's the shaving
i'm
some of them do some pretty gnarly like
positions to get the freaking leg hair
off that's true i didn't think that yeah
you're hitting like weird like you're
probably like
unbalanced at some point
yeah yeah that's why i take a bath
you can shave in the bathtub
[Music]
[Music]